i want to do a quick overview of
trigonometry and the aspects of trig
functions that are important to us as
electrical engineers so this isn't meant
to be a full class on trigonometry if
you haven't had this subject before this
is something that you can study on khan
academy and sal does a lot of good
videos on on trig functions and how they
work
so the way i remember my trig functions
is with
the phrase
so
car
toa
so this is the little phrase i use to
remember how to do my trig functions we
draw a triangle like this right triangle
with an angle here of theta
and we label the sides
of the triangle as this is the side
adjacent to theta
this is the side
opposite of theta
and this side over here is the
hypotenuse
of the triangle
so this says that
the definition of sine
of theta
equals
opposite over hypotenuse opposite
over hypotenuse
this phrase here means the cosine
of theta
equals
adjacent over hypotenuse
and the last one here is for the tangent
it says the tangent of theta
equals
opposite over adjacent opposite divided
by adjacent opposite
over adjacent
so
sokatoa helps you remember your trig
functions
so let's take that idea over here
and draw
a line out
and make some calculations
we're we have a graph here of our a unit
circle that means the radius of this is
1 everywhere
and what i want to know is here's my
angle theta
and angles are measured
from the positive x-axis
here's the x-axis
here's the y-axis
angles are measured going
counterclockwise
so let's talk for a second about how
angles are measured angles are measured
in two ways angles are measured
in degrees
from 0 to 360.
and angles are also measured in
something called radians
and that goes from 0 to
2 pi
so these are two different angle
measures
and when you're measuring in degrees we
put the little degree mark up here
that's what that means radians don't get
a degree mark on them
so if i mark this out in degrees
here's 0 degrees
here's 90 degrees
here's 180 degrees
this is 270.
and when i get back to the beginning
it's 360 degrees
if i measure the same angles and radians
this will be zero radians
when i get back here it's going to be
2 pi radians
going all the way around the circle is 2
pi radians that means that going halfway
around the circle
is pi
radians that's equivalent to 180 degrees
if i do a quarter of a circle
that's equal to pi over 2
radians
and if i do three quarters of a circle
that's three halves pi or
three pi
over two
so we'll use degrees and radians all the
time and we'll flip back and forth
between them
so now let's do some trig functions on
our angle
theta right in here
let's work out the sine cosine and
tangent
now let me give a a name to this
hypotenuse let's call that r
and r r equals 1 right i said this was a
unit circle so r is equal to 1.
and when we calculate our right triangle
what we do is we drop a perpendicular
down here
to the x-axis
and we also draw a horizontal over here
from the y-axis
this side right here this section of the
x-axis right here is the side adjacent
to the angle theta and this side this
distance right here on this side of our
triangle is the side opposite
okay and basically there's going to be a
a y-intercept here and a little
x-intercept right here where those
happen these will be some number
depending on the tilt of this angle of
this line here
right so the sine
of theta
is equal to what is equal to
let's look at our definition it's equal
to opposite over hypotenuse
opposite is y
over the hypotenuse which is r
if i look at cosine
theta
adjacent over hypotenuse adjacent is the
x distance
and the hypotenuse is r
and if we do the tangent
of theta
that equals what it's opposite over
adjacent so it's opposite which is the y
distance
over
x
the adjacent x is the adjacent
now one thing to notice here about
tangent y over x
is the
rise divided by the run going from this
point
up to this point
so that is the slope
so the idea of slope and the idea of
tangent are really closely related
just as one small point let's let's work
out what is 1 radian what's an angle of
1 radian
in degrees
i can do that conversion just doing some
units
if we have
180 degrees
that equals pi
radians
so that means that 1 radian
equals 180 over pi
if you plug that in the calculator
it'll come out to
57.3 roughly degrees
so one radian actually is a little above
45 degrees one radian is
57 degrees it looks about like that
we don't use this very often mostly we
talk about radians in terms of multiples
of pi because it makes more sense on
this circle but just to let you know
that's that's roughly one radian